This is Tom the Taxi Driver,
London cabbie with a
YouTube channel,
which means you have
the Knowledge.
The Knowledge of London,
the formal testing, examination
that every single London
taxi driver must do
to be able to drive the
iconic black cab.
So how long did it take you?
It took me just under
three years,
and its average is probably about
between two and four years.
And it's every road within
six miles of London, is it, or...?
The six mile radius of
King Charles I Island,
which is roughly the
geographic centre of London.
And it could be any road,
point of interest.
Examiners can ask you
anything within that area.
So it's just a good idea to try
and learn as much as possible.
So you've got that in your head.
Yes.
And I'm gonna have a phone.
And the producers have
laid out two routes for us.
They're gonna tell us
each point to go to in turn,
and our individual routes
have been set.
So by GPS, they should take
exactly the same amount of time.
You, on the other hand,
don't have to follow the GPS.
You get to use
all the shortcuts
and all the knowledge
that's in your head.
And I'm hoping there
should be some shortcuts
and hopefully some
knowledge in here as well.
We're gonna start
just around the corner.
I've got something that
looks like a cab but isn't.
You have an actual London cab.
My own taxi that I take
passengers in normally.
Yep.
Alright.
Good luck.
Be lucky, Tom.
See you at the finish.
Okay.
Hello.
How are we doing?
I'm good. How are you?
Let's do this.
Right, where to?
Where to? Well...
A blue plaque of
Ada Lovelace, where she lived.
Oh, on St James's Square.
Correct.
Gosh, you're good.
So we are going to
Mary Shelley's
blue plaque, please.
Mary Shelley's blue—
that involves research!
Oh, it's fine.
Google has it.
That's what I thought.
Mary Shelley Blue Plaque.
Yes, please.
Okay.
Head northwest on Rotary Street
towards Borough Road/A3202
Right. Handbrake off,
into drive.
Away we go.
And turn left onto Borough Road.
So we haven't,
obviously haven't got the...
luxury of traffic updates
here, have we?
We've just got you.
No, I've got no phone or
anything up in front of me.
So, on a normal working
day to day,
I will have a phone up.
Not necessarily to put
stuff in navigation,
but just to understand what the
streets and the roads are doing.
So important things to say.
First of all, I am required
to follow all traffic laws.
I am required to
follow the speed limit.
I'm required to drive as I
normally would in London,
which is kind of
what I'm used to.
I'm also required to
follow the GPS,
even if I know it would
currently be quicker
to go down that road and right.
I've gotta follow the GPS.
Yeah, at least you
get to do U-turns, right?
Some streets, there'll be
a no U-turn sign.
Yeah.
Don't wanna do one there,
because you'll get a fine
in the post, but yeah.
We have quite a tight
turning circle,
meaning that we don't
prohibit traffic too much
when we turn.
Is it gonna be really hard
for you not going in bus lanes?
Yeah, I've almost nearly...
I mean, there's one
coming up here,
so thank you for
reminding me, Kirsten.
I'm not allowed to use
bus lanes today,
because I am not a licensed
taxi driver, so legally I can't.
So I will get undertaken
in just a moment...
by an actual London cab who is
probably gonna be wondering
Turn left onto Lambeth Road/A3203.
why I'm not there with him.
That taxi driver that just passed you
did just give you a very peculiar look.
I mean, there's...
To be fair, there's four cameras
attached to the vehicle.
I mean, I am somewhat glad that
Tom has to abide by the satnav.
Yeah.
Because I feel like he has
a very, very good knowledge
of London as it is.
Yeah.
Through sheer osmosis.
I guess the good thing about Tom
being in a taxi looking vehicle though,
is that he will probably get treated
slightly differently on the roads.
Definitely.
If we put him in a
really small car,
and he is trying to pull out
of certain junctions...
It's quite difficult, I'd imagine.
At the roundabout, take
the second exit onto A3203.
I mean, obviously I'm doing
the speed limit because it's legal.
But of course.
But also because
I know that if I don't,
someone is going to be
analysing the shot behind,
and checking the speed
that I'm going.
Whoa, braking.
I sort of wish I knew
where Tom was.
Or how he's getting on,
or if he's stressing or panicking.
I'm starting to get
properly frustrated
with everyone else in
London now.
It's interesting.
Do you feel more frustrated
because you're in the
energy of a black cab?
Here we go, we're not far now.
We're just gonna do a right
here into Marlborough Road.
Okay.
And then, St James's Square,
almost after that.
Okay.
I keep expecting to see
Tom in the other cab,
and then I remember we're
not going the same route.
We're not racing.
No, you're not racing.
We're not gonna see each
other until the finish line.
Whoever gets there first.
Oh, I see a blue plaque.
There we go.
Chatham House.
Not that one.
That's a different one.
Ah.
Ada Love...
Yeah, Ada Lovelace.
There we go.
Ah-mazing!
Pioneer of computing lived here.
Stop off number one is gonna
be on your right very shortly.
Lovely, oh.
So we're looking for
a blue plaque.
And I'm gonna pull in here.
Your destination is on the right.
We are close enough
that the GPS is okay with it.
Hazards are on.
Right.
And handbrake on.
Off you go.
Let's go find.
(door closes)
Mary Shelley.
Author of Frankenstein,
lived here for a bit.
Right, let's go get
back in the cab.
Have we got it?
If you wonder what the
beeping is, that's the
'passenger has left
the door open' alarm.
'Ello, right.
(posh accent) Hello.
Do close the door
after you, please.
These were the
beeping in here.
Right, next one please.
Where are we off to?
Ah, hello.
I'm a very fancy lady, and I would
like to go to Liberty please.
Hello, madam.
(posh accent) Hello, old chap.
I'd like to go to Harrods, please.
What a rather dashing
hat you've got there.
Thank you very much.
So you wish to go to Harrods.
Right, okay, I hopefully
know where that is.
Okay, good.
This is bread and butter stuff now.
Good, yeah.
Most optimum route, 'cause...
This has gotten a bit easier now.
This will all count, won't it?
Let's go up via
Duke of York Street.
So we don't have to go
back around the square.
So I actually do know
where Liberty is.
That is just southeast
of Oxford Circus.
So...
In 150 yards, turn right
onto Elizabeth Street.
Let's see, what would I do?
Straight on the Piccadilly Underpass.
A4, fair left Brompton Road.
Bosh.
Yeah, is that our route?
That is.
Nailed?
Nailed.
When did you put a—
Did you put a tiara on
when I wasn't looking?
Mm-yes.
It's 'cause I'm a very fancy lady
who's going to Liberty
to buy presents
for her grandchildren.
I didn't realise we were doing
improv characters here as we went.
So are there any sneaky shortcuts
on this route that we're going?
Not really, it's a straight road.
Okay.
So...
We're lucky that it's not
Changing the Guard,
because that whole area
where we've just come from...
Yeah.
Does get quite gridlocked,
'cause you can't...
All the traffic that would normally
go past Buckingham Palace...
Right.
Comes out on these roads.
Okay.
But we are looking good.
There's gonna be a
load of little streets,
between Park Lane and
Oxford Circus, that Tom knows.
Now, this is one of the roads in London
that you can't actually do a U-turn on.
There's a no U-turn sign here.
Oh really?
And there used to be a camera
that was active to give people a fine.
So as much as I do
want to beat Tom Scott...
Yeah, you can't break
can't break the law.
I dunno, 60 pound fine
seems worth it.
(cackles)
is it weird that we're
both called Tom?
Is that gonna cause you any
any production problems?
Well it certainly caused
some pre-production problems.
And by problems, I mean,
it's just been very confusing.
But it's all right.
Go, go, go.
If you'd have looked.
I've just realised my window open.
I have just realised
my window was open.
I wonder what the vibe
is in Tom's cab.
I can't wait to see this later on.
Turn left to stay on Piccadilly.
This is Hyde Park Corner.
It is...
only just worse than
Marble Arch up north.
Sir, there's a Harrods sign there.
This is it. This is
Harrods here, sorry.
Can I get out?
I'll wait until we get
up to the curb,
just cause we wanna...
Just to be safe.
The GPS has done wonders here.
I would never have gone
up Piccadilly,
'cause most of the time,
this is absolutely blocked up.
Like, this would've been
stop-go traffic
all the way back
to that roundabout.
But it's clear most of the way to
the Ritz and Piccadilly Circus.
Okay, yeah, you got it?
Okay, great.
Right, next one.
What's our ETA
to the next location?
Oh, sorry, I should do that
in my posh woman's voice.
Please, peasant, when are we
arriving at my next location?
By next location, the only
location I want to go to in this?
Well, Madam...
Thank you.
It is six minutes away,
more or less.
Delightful.
Hey man.
Hello madam.
I'd like to go to Jimi Hendrix's
house, please, man.
I can see the resemblance.
Very psychedelic look
you've got there, madam.
Do you know the address?
It's on Brook Street.
You're absolutely right.
Look at this.
Oh, am I in the right lane?
Am I in the right lane?
(rolling sigh)
Tom the Taxi Driver
would absolutely know
if he's in the right lane.
I do not.
Oh, yes, I am.
That's more by luck
than good judgement.
Oh, this is fantastic.
Yeah?
This normally can
build up quite bad here.
Really?
I tell you why I use this, right?
Knightsbridge is very bad
when you get towards...
if we did a U-turn
where we was.
Yeah.
I normally jump on this road,
and there's a very neat
bus lane here along the left.
I'm not using it.
Oh, that you couldn't use.
But you can't.
But, there's no one here.
One thing I know is that
I get updates on road closures,
'cause like the GPS
will update very quickly
if there's a blocked road.
Turn left onto
Great Marlborough Street.
He probably won't know
about things like that,
unless he sort of gets
updates over the...
So is there cab CB radio
or anything that
updates when something's closed?
I was gonna say, or is there
a cabbie WhatsApp group
that they're all in?
Maybe.
Or go up Park Lane?
There's gonna be some level
of traffic on Park Lane.
I can guarantee that.
Okay. Okay.
It's just how much.
In 200 yards, your
destination will be on the left.
Alright, so Liberty's
coming up on the left.
It's a Tudor framed
building up here.
I'm gonna try and find somewhere
to park just in front of it.
Might have gone wrong here.
I should have maybe gone through
the underpass and through—
Really?
I will look at, yeah,
Park Lane doesn't look great.
That underpass would have
saved us a bit of time.
No bother.
We just remain relaxed.
Smooth is fast.
Yeah, stay chill.
And away you go.
Thank you very much, sir.
I shall tip you well.
By which I say, not at all.
Fast as you can please.
Great.
Let's go.
I'm finding NordVPN really useful,
because I'm on the road so much.
I haven't been back to London
since we shot the taxi video.
This isn't some influencer
paid to talk about it thing.
I mean, I have been paid
to talk about it,
but NordVPN really is
installed on my laptop,
and I really do keep using it.
If I want to access a site that's
blocked in some country I'm in,
or I'm trying to access
something back in the UK,
and I keep being shown the local
site in some other language instead?
Well, now I can just click the
button on my laptop or my phone,
and that site or app will think I'm
in one of about 60 other countries.
Or that I'm just back in the UK.
It's fast, it's secure, and
one subscription is enough
to connect six devices
at the same time.
You can also try it out for
30 days with no commitment.
If it's not for you,
you can change your mind,
and NordVPN will give you a refund.
They also offer a password
manager called NordPass,
so if you're still not using
a password manager,
that's worth looking into as well.
If you go to
nordvpn.com/tomscottplus
you'll find the best deal
they're currently offering.
Right, back to me
in a black cab
driving around London.
Okay, so this is great
so far, Berkeley Square.
This is definitely gonna be quicker
than what was going up Park Lane.
Okay, so we might have
pulled it back a bit here.
Yeah.
He's gotta also work with the
satnav, so there's a lot of...
inputting stuff.
Yeah.
You a new character?
Hello.
I am the ghost of
Sir Isaac Newton. Please—
You are the ghost of
Sir Is— Well that's—
Please, take me to a
place that I once lived.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna have to do
research, aren't I?
Right, fine.
Hand brake on.
And presumably
the cabbies all know
Isaac Newton's old house,
and I'm...
Alright, Isaac Newt—
Okay, nine minutes away.
Head northeast on Great Marlborough Street
towards Carnaby Street.
Sure, let's do that.
Okay. It's...
London Ultra Low Emission
Zone on route.
It's U-turn time!
How far away do you
reckon we are, Tom?
We are just at the
end of Davies Street.
We're gonna do a right,
so two minutes,
depending on what
that traffic light does.
I appreciate the effort
you've gone to,
to have different characters pick up.
Thank you!
Turn right onto Berwick Street,
then turn right onto D'Arblay Street.
Don't you dare, don't
you dare, don't you dare.
Right, I'm going through here.
Here we go.
So this is Claridge's
on the right hand side.
If we get through these
lights on Brook Street,
Yeah.
We'll be turning right.
Okay.
And I'll be able to
drop us just opposite.
Okay. Perfect.
When I'm being
undertaken by a cyclist,
this doesn't feel like
the fastest route.
I dunno, maybe Tom's
stuck in traffic as well.
And there will now be an ironic cut
to either Tom stuck in traffic,
or Tom just bombing it
down Park Lane.
I see the blue plaque.
It's where that scaffolding
is on the right hand side.
Is it?
Yes.
Handel and Hendrix,
that's the Handel one.
George Frideric Handel.
Oh, Hendrix next door,
there we go.
Oh, there we go.
I'm gonna stop it safely here.
Okay, I'm getting out.
Cool.
Now, GPS has got a big red
patch ahead, which worries me.
Nice. Okay, let's do it.
That street was entirely empty.
I could have sped down that.
And instead the GPS has sent
me down here, which I...
Which is empty, get in!
GPS said it wasn't.
GPS said it was
bright red on there.
Howdy. (giggles)
So I thought,
I'm on a hen do,
and I've gotta get to
Holborn Station, please.
Holborn Station.
Oh, nice. That's not a very
attractive hen do location.
Well, I'm getting
the tube out to Essex.
There's a part of my brain that
wants to treat this like it's a race.
It's not, this is an experiment.
I've gotta drive normally.
It's fine.
So I'm just quelling the
part of my brain that's going,
"Go on, go on.
You can take that."
So Holborn Station,
the actual frontage,
and hopefully you'll be able to
see it from where we are outside.
Yeah.
Hold on a minute,
it's in a one-way system.
So how am I gonna get there?
Ah, this is gonna be
really bad actually.
There's work going on
Bloomsbury Way,
which is the main road
of getting there.
So many pedestrians,
so few of them looking
before they cross the road.
In 200 yards, your destination
will be on the left.
Approaching on the left
very shortly.
Isaac Newton's place.
Let's see where I'm parking.
I'm gonna park just here
on the right.
Isaac Newton's place is
just ahead on the left,
and...
you're off.
I'm not looking forward to
this one, if I'm completely honest.
Really?
Yeah.
So geographically we
might have worked it all out,
but it's the time wise
of getting through it.
Right.
Please tell me I can
take the wig off now.
Yeah.
So this is our final stop
before the last stop.
Wow, okay.
This is our penultimate
stop, I should say.
I think I'm getting
more anxious as it goes on.
Another costume,
another character. Let me guess.
I'm going on my hen do up north.
Alright.
So I need you take
to Kings Cross, please love.
Kings Cross Station.
Yes, please.
So now we're on Oxford Street.
Okay.
This is the moment of truth.
We turn left and we,
shock horror...
Oh, it's looking good.
And not too bad.
It's looking good.
So those buses
are stopped by that light,
and there's no one at
Tottenham Court Road.
Okay, great.
That is very good.
I'm pleased so far.
London Ultra Low
Emission Zone on route.
You don't need to tell me that.
I'm already in the
London Low Emission Zone.
Alright, cool.
We are— Oh my god,
24 minutes for this run.
Whew!
This is gonna be a slow one.
I got a big red warning on my GPS.
I just hope that Tom
is having a very fun time.
(laugh blurt)
I hope he's hit
shed loads of traffic.
(guttural groan)
There has to be a
faster way through this.
There has to be.
Sadly though,
there is no other way.
If it was my limitations
of Knowledge...
Yeah.
I would be very upset.
For this second time 'round,
it's taken us up here.
And... it does look clear.
It is tight, but frankly the
turn circle does help on this.
No one behind.
Plenty in front.
It would be great
if people didn't walk
in front of the car
at this present moment.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're fine now.
Oh, smashed it!
To be fair to the GPS, I haven't
been stuck in traffic once yet.
Yeah, this is true.
I'm just not convinced it's
taking you the best route, but...
Turn right onto Great Russell Street.
Once we straighten up,
go past the British Museum,
I've gotta look ahead and
see what my options are.
There's a couple of ways
of exiting off of it.
Got you.
That's them!
Where?
Right behind us.
In 200 yards, turn left
onto Montague Street.
You're kidding.
Nope.
And they just passed us, I think.
I feel so lost.
Oh no, don't.
Oh no.
Are they going north?
They are going north.
Oh, we've lost it then,
we've lost it.
There's nothing I can do.
Not necessarily.
So you've got the tracker.
Are they following us?
Are we going the same way?
We are not. No.
Alright.
So that was just a coincidence.
It was a complete chance
that we just crossed paths.
Okay...
Options, options.
Okay, we're not far now, right?
Not far as the crow flies, but
there will be invariably traffic.
This is absolutely not a race.
I may or may not
be ahead of them.
It doesn't matter.
I'm just driving as I normally would.
Oh god.
This is painful.
It could be worse, Kirsten.
The metre could be running.
Ha! This is so true.
About this time, you'd
probably be right to complain
about the metre steadily
ticking up, you know.
That's true.
Although the metre stopped.
I don't actually
know how to work it.
Number was too big.
No one gave me instructions
for the metre.
Here we go.
Yes.
Freedom!
I'm getting competitive now.
That's not my—
My job is to drive like your
average mini cab driver.
Yeah.
Follow the GPS.
Do what it tells me.
I am an interface between
Google Maps and the passengers.
And my job is not to get
overcompetitive
about the fact it
sent me a terrible way.
Holborn Station's coming up.
I'm sure you know, madam,
that this is your appropriate train
to get you back to Essex.
Right, we're nearly there.
Ohh.
There is an official pick-up
and drop-off point here.
Out I get.
Should be open now, yeah.
Holborn Station.
Thank you.
I'll be here somewhere.
This appears to be a
valid set-down point.
I might be further along.
Oh, lovely.
Go.
Thank you very much.
Have a good day!
It's really busy now.
This is so embarrassing!
Okay, great.
Let's go, next stop.
Good?
Good, right.
One last stop.
Okay.
Final stop, Gibson Square.
Gibson Square?
Do you like my moustache?
You seem to have grown
caterpillar upon your top lip.
The things you do for your job.
Alright.
Do we have another character
or are you just you now?
Oh no.
Oh— (laughs uproariously)
Where are we headed to?
We are going to
Gibson Square, please sir.
My name's Mr. Taxi,
and Gibson Square has
some kind of importance to
when you learned the Knowledge.
Right.
Can't remember what it is.
Gibson Square it is.
It's in the GPS.
Let's go.
Yeah, so Gibson Square,
that is particularly
memorable for you, right?
Every London cabbie,
possibly anyone
who's ever tried attempting
the Knowledge.
Yeah.
The very first run goes
from Manor House Station...
Yeah.
off of Green Lanes,
if we were at Manor House.
Yeah.
to Gibson Square.
Yeah, hopefully I know
where Gibson Square is.
So everyone has to
learn Gibson Square.
Doing the Knowledge.
Yeah.
So here's the thing,
I couldn't U-turn there.
Right.
There's no easy way to do that.
And the GPS had
a bit of a problem,
and it's now stuck on re-routing.
Oh.
I just hope that Tom
has had a good day out.
I was meant to say
thank you to the cab behind.
I forgot there was this
little plastic thing there.
Did you just slam it?
Whacked my hand on that.
I want Tom to do well.
Aw, that's nice.
I want to see people seeing
him drive across London
and go, that's Tom Scott
driving a black cab.
Oh yeah, that all happened.
And then you know
the seas parted for him.
You know, come on Tom.
My GPS is just stuck on re-routing.
It doesn't even know where I am.
And I am right in the middle
of Kings Cross with full 5G.
So I'm just gonna have to
find somewhere safe to stop.
Here we go, that's a lay-by.
Alright, we're gonna stop here.
I'm gonna have to join
the start of that route,
and then just try and follow it.
There's no other way to do it.
I'm kind of a pessimist
by heart anyway.
We're gonna turn up, he's gonna
be in Gibson Square, smiling.
So true.
Looking at me saying,
"Where did you get to?"
(laughs)
And that'll be forever emblazoned—
"What took you so long?"
He's gonna say something
like that, isn't he?
That's gonna be emblazoned in my
brain for the rest of my eternity.
And I will no longer be able to
complete my job as a cab driver.
I might as well hand him my badge.
But I forgot just how mentally
tiring it is to constantly do this.
I dunno how Tom does it
for hours and hours.
♪ Drive, drive, drive your car
gently down the road ♪
♪ Merrily, merrily, merrily...
obey the highway code ♪
Oh my god, it's so close.
Oh.
It's actually so close.
Oh no.
Like it's ridiculously close.
Don't say that.
I actually can't cope
with how close this is.
Two minutes to go
until we're there,
and I suspect I know what
I'm gonna find when I get there.
Really? Mm...
I don't think there's any way
I could never say.
I don't think there's
any way I've won this one.
It's not a race.
It's not a race, but also...
I don't think there's any
way I've won this one.
I really wanna just see him
just go ding, like past us here.
I honestly think we could
be seeing him very soon.
If he does, I'm just gonna
blare the horn and be like,
"Nooo!"
I think the thing I'm
most happy about is that
at no point have I made
any illegal manoeuvres.
Yep.
At no point have I misread
the GPS or gone the wrong way.
That was a very stressful drive.
Turn left onto Gibson Square.
Then you will arrive
at your destination.
Oh yeah, I see Gibson Square.
This is it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where's a TX4?
This is us, right?
Yeah, this is us,
but I can't see a TX4.
Right, well pull in then!
Pull in!
No way!
Have we won?
I can't see him.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my word, please.
Oh my god, have we won?
No way.
(both squealing)
Where is he?
Tom?!
Is he here?
Did we win?
I think we did.
Yes!
Yes, beat that, Tom Scott.
Gibson Square.
Aww!
Oh, there we go!
No way!
I'll park up and
talk to you in a minute.
See you in a sec.
Yeah, I don't think I stood
a chance there, did I?
Well done though.
How close was it?
We was here for about
20 minutes, mate.
Honestly, we've only just pulled up.
Really?
I know that everyone's like,
"Oh, it's so close!"
and stuff like that.
I thought you had won that.
Do you think you could have
done it without that,
with your knowledge already?
Absolutely not. Absolutely not.
Really?
Because you are always
around London.
You know London, you've been
here, you've drove here.
I've driven some of these roads.
But I would've hit traffic
two or three times.
I would've been in the wrong lane.
I would've gone the wrong way.
Right.
And trying to navigate that
last half mile would've got me.
I think, yeah, Google
or whoever you use,
whatever you use,
has let you down there, but...
It's all variables.
Well done, man.
Thank you Tom.
It's been a pleasure.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]